so the first of all
one should always be fair trump is
one of those people who
are instantly and obviously
hard ruthless and you've got to admire
the power of the verbal punch they pack
like he's not a very intelligent speaker
but the way he speaks he like dumbs it
down for people
he like he the way he speaks he he hits
a primal part of your brain
that just makes certain people react
very strongly
yes you're dealing with a primeval
monster
who who takes you back into the slime
from whence we came
and that works he speaks from the gut to
the gut
and if you don't look after yourself
with him he'll hurt you
and because you know that
it's right to fear him the problem is
managing your fear while
you're dealing with him because he can
say something so
vicious that it that it can silence you
or you're left gasping and i think what
happened
with hillary was that hillary never
quite
got through there's a beautiful moment
thinking of my
uh grand unborn grand unborn grand
daughter's bet for 500 quid on joe to
win
when joe says to him well you just shut
up man
remember in the first debate and that
was a kind of
wonderful moment because it showed like
joe's well i was you know
joe's obviously he's going on a bit his
granddaddy
can't remember where the keys to the
garage are he's a big gargar
but he's not he's not a patsy one of my
favorite movies
um is now how have we got the right
title
the last show with art carney
have you seen it no a wonderful movie
suddenly
it's in the 70s and it's about art
carney
who's a wonderful actor who in real life
had a limp
and so he limps and he's an old private
eye and he speaks
in 1940s roman chandler the big sleep
style slang um
and he there's a crazy
hippie woman who comes to him with some
stuff about a cat
but behind the uh the cat story
something dark is happening and
in this kind of moment of poetry and
beauty
the old private eye um
slowly untangles the darkness the
gangsters
and becomes a hero
even though he's old he's got something
wrong with him
um he's got some kind of bad stomach
ulcer
and every now and he collapses and at
one point the baddies
beat him up and he coughs blood and then
a critical moment the baddies
have got the upper hand and he collapses
but he's mucking about and he's got his
gun and he says
listen son you're in trouble
and it's kind of beautiful and there was
a moment
the moment when joe said listen ma'am
when you shut up was the art carny
moments
in the in that debate um and it was
and the thing about joe was that joe
isn't money and he kind of gets standing
up
for himself and standing up for the
people he represents
so there was although grandad is a bit
uh is far too well and doesn't know
where he's left the keys
he's up for a fight that was a sweet
moment trump's very impressive
the other thing which is squalored about
trump and i hated
was his transactionalism if
um like if i were to meet you um if i
you know if the world gets good again
and i can fly uh to florida and
yeah amazing we could sit here and drink
wine together yeah well
what i'd do is um to be honest
i'd get a bottle of italian red and i
sit on the park bench opposite the
church
of scientology and i'd go
for a bit then then i'd grow up
then we'd go we'd hire um
we should do this anyway we'd hire a
soft top convertible
drive around the nice bits of florida
find
a lovely bar by the beach i'd go for a
great big long swim because i like doing
that
and then and then we'd come back and eat
ribs and drink good wine and talk about
the world
and
at any point if i paid for all of that
because i've got lots of money i don't
i'm just fantasizing i wouldn't think
for a second that i
owned you because i paid it paid for it
trump would so what happened with trump
was that when we arrived
we were going to interview him on the
tuesday but on the saturday of the
sunday
we went to is it bedminster his
golf resort in new jersey
i'm not sure the name of it he's got a
golf resort in new jersey i think it's
called bedminster or something like this
um and um it's the mar-a-lago of new
jersey
and um
he was great in terms of tv he was great
he said
hi john great to meet you they're
looking after you it's wonderful really
good he gave me a uh
a trump hat not make america grumpy
again but from gold
red hat fantastic um very useful because
i've got a bald head i used to drive it
around
i used to wear it when i drove my soft
top vw beetle around i don't do that
anymore let somebody kill me
but um
anyway i um i ended up um
we're in a golf buggy uh together and um
he he said okay john and um
he gives me a lift and he goes off of
dune like really quite
a high speed and you can hear me i'm on
the
the end of the um of the capacity
of my sound mic feeding back to the
camera
but as we disappear in the lighted frame
so we're dying
the light is dying but as the light dies
and we head off into the sunset
you can clearly clearly hear me say
i'm a bit worried about the driver
because this [ __ ] lunatic is gonna
kill me um
and that was trump and then
it was just you and him in the golf cart
yeah yeah yeah it's on power arm it's a
bbc panorama uh
you know trump the kremlin candidate
question mark and
um and that's me and and then he
he organized for us to go up in his
trump helicopter
and fly around the golf course all of
which is wonderful pictures
he's not there he's doing something else
but
but what this means is that when i come
down to sit and interview him
he thinks he owns me
now you know i've been in a golf buggy
before
i don't like golf i think it ruins a
good walk
um but um i have been in a golf buggy
and i've been in lots of helicopters
times with the american marines in the
american army in northern iraq
and all sorts of [ __ ] weird and
crazy places but the idea that you can
buy my soul
for a ride in a golf buggy and a rider
helicopter
that's just foolish and
the story i was there to ask him about
was that he
he um built this golf course in the
in scotland but he'd fallen out with um
his scottish neighbors because he
treated them
appallingly um and there's a problem
with the way
trump treats ordinary people who get in
this way
that was the purpose of the film